hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you what's going
on I know it's Friday Jesus dude you
like a whole [ __ ] day late you're a
whole afternoon late
well I'm sorry man
that's all I can say I made a mistake
and I if you could fight it in yeah to
forgive me
we shot late yesterday we went until
4:00 a.m. I was on set Oh Billy
Hollywood si delivering a line and a
half of a seated staff yeah we were out
there until 3:30 in the morning and how
we kept it light is we were all doing
our impression of Jay Moore's impression
of Harvey Keitel so we were all just
butchering it you know talking to the
director Judd I'm trying to remember how
that came out what the [ __ ] we was
saying Judd I don't know if you know
what you're doing he's a good actor just
butchering it if you gotta listen to the
Jays impression of what the [ __ ] are we
do we are you a doctor I know it's
horrible but Jays is [ __ ] right on
the money and like a lot of impressions
what you're doing is the impression of
the guy's impression that got it right
so that's what the [ __ ] we were doing we
were at a Staten Island the Staten
Island Yankees Stadium I don't from a
lot of to [ __ ] say this show whatever
was shooting therefore I'm credible
minor league stadium with with the best
view of New York City of any ballpark
you know you would think Yankee Stadium
home of the New York Egg is a 27 World
Series championships the most
championships of any professionals
Steve and olive for sports links you
would think that they would have this
incredible view of New York City and
they don't it's kind of weird
it's weird that the breathtaking view is
actually from a single a I don't know
but that's also part of their [ __ ]
organization so maybe maybe it all works
out I don't [ __ ] know so how are you
what does happen what has been happening
in the world you know I promised on
Monday I teased it old school podcasting
that I was gonna have the lovely Nia on
and she was going to talk about being us
physically battered in Times Square well
as we've learned assault is just the the
threat of violence battery is actually
carrying out the act like yeah I know
that's a weird [ __ ] thing you know
what I mean I was [ __ ] assaulted I
was attacked you were attacked but you
you were battered okay yeah cuz she made
contact with me she made contact I
thought she just pushed his a deal we
was we was walking minding our own
business we were we were we got off the
subway and we were going in Times Square
a couple blocks up coming down from the
Upper West Side there right and we got
off on what is it 49th Street or
something like that
50th Street and we were walking down to
Times Square then we had just bombs like
wow there's a lot look at little he's
[ __ ] people here some Times Square
was never this crowded yeah and somebody
I was with was like now it's always been
this crowded it's like now it wasn't
when I first moved here this was all
like porno shops and shady people and it
was it wasn't like this wasn't an M&M
store and a bunch of people going to go
see the [ __ ] Lion King I love how you
keep like saying this as if like you
weren't here when all that stuff
happened you were here when all that
stuff started to change you're acting
like you're like the narrator from
[ __ ] taxi driver or something like oh
you know this
it is full of grit and grim it's like
you were here when it was like cleaned
up and touristy why do you keep talking
like you're because it wasn't like
you're looking back on it like you're
some you know 70s [ __ ] grizzled guy
I'm not saying that it wasn't when we
when we left here together like when we
left I came here in 94 I know but like
all that stuff had already like changed
when we left when we moved to LA so it's
not like you weren't here for the M&M
store and all the things that have
happened since then that's what I'm
saying
you I don't understand what you're
saying when I came here I know but
you're also like but you're acting like
you came here and wow I'm back now and
it's so different you were here when
those all those changes yeah this city
turns since we left turn into a giant
yeah turned into a giant Bed Bath and
Beyond but I feel like it was like that
we love no I'm not crazy you're crazy
okay no I guess it wasn't that crap it
wasn't it's to work in Times Square when
I worked at MTV and I don't remember it
being that crazy I remember working
there and The Naked Cowboy was still
around remember The Naked Cowboy yeah
but even that was part of a sillier time
I remember when I when I first came here
there was a Howard Johnson's in Times
Square with a payphone that I sat on
with a stack of [ __ ] quarters or
whatever the [ __ ] it cost calling people
cold calling people like I was in
Glengarry Glen Ross trying to find a
place where I could I could I could have
a room in an apartment and they put me
on holy app but up but uh you know
that's what it when it was Shady
mm-hmm so yeah and when all of a sudden
there was a you know
let's see 94 95 I don't win to the M&M
store came in but it was somewhere they
got Giuliani was just starting to clean
it up
Tompkins Square Park was just all
[ __ ] junkies when we were here I do
remember the M&M store it just as always
struck me funny that like an
afterthought candy would somehow get
this spin-off that became this huge hit
it is [ __ ] that it's a whole store I get
the Hershey store which is way
smaller but always been in the game they
have those commercials that one that
comes on every Christmas when Santa
comes down he was like they are real
like he is real and then he faints and
then the yellow one goes Oh Santa this
you know what this is Nia this is the
generation gap between you and me coz
I'm so emotionally mature
yeah well cuz you're so old and I just
forget I forgot you're a decade older
than me that's right and I landed you I
know I took the best years of my life
Oh Billy grizzled nuts somehow ran you
down
caught you sleeping at the [ __ ]
watering hole there in the Serengeti
scared I've didn't I did I pulled you in
the deep water wait wait assault and
battery how about that you got battered
first and then she assaulted you with
her words I mean whatever the [ __ ] it
was I don't do it I'm not a lawyer all
right upset I got one microphone sir you
got so we're walking down there and I'm
remembering my [ __ ] New York and you
like you here with a [ __ ] game here
do you used to be peep shows and Boas
people it did yeah you this an 80 year
old person saying the same thing and you
give them [ __ ] no you were here with the
M&M store came what if the [ __ ] does
that mean
no the eighty year old person I'd be
like yeah sure but I just feel like
you're doing this like weird like New
York beat but you were here longer
before no this is you just [ __ ] on
me for no [ __ ] reason at all I'm
literally telling you my [ __ ]
experience why is your shirt open like
what's going on right now cuz I was
gonna change into a t-shirt and then I
said oh [ __ ] I got to do this podcast
because they're gonna come to pick me up
and I got the tunes takuya this is cool
in the gang with [ __ ] stick your
balls and some ice
the mustache is [ __ ] painful yeah
this baby alright someone you give
Starsky a little hot Jovi every once in
awhile
sorry okay
so we get off and evidently I am waxing
poetically as you like to say about I
don't know what I mean I literally knew
I went to the [ __ ] peep shows I'm not
gonna say what the comedians we first
came but he took the bus down we got off
at the Port Authority it was it was the
dirtiest [ __ ] grossest place ever
[Music]
it's just like every time you're old yes
every time Time Square comes up you're
down there I mean what is going on it's
like every single time you say that I
just think it's a funny store
I guess I got a wetland I don't let's
get back to the fact that they have
their own [ __ ] store I mean I'm not
trying to disrespect them I'm not trying
to disrespect them like that on the
level of KitKat but they're not her.she
her.she was like the greatest generation
World War two is like blow like one of
the lower run candies because I strongly
object to that myself
whose kid no all right all right
like how do I you're gonna put into like
a band okay all right yeah if you're
gonna think of you say like this this
band is a derivative of that band or
they're a wannabe this band Eminem's
they're like there's weird sort of like
I don't know what kind of band there I
don't want to [ __ ] on anybody you're
trying to find a reason to trash mm
they're like the old school like they
are like the consistent the consistent
top they got with are they worthy of a
the stores like three floors high and
you walk through Times Square yeah we
see somebody with those [ __ ] yellow
bags it's like what the [ __ ] are you
buying you can get M&Ms at a [ __ ]
deli but they also have
the merch they have like the plushies of
all the M&M characters that are in the
commercials
I never say plushies again okay they
have merch okay and then they have like
shirts and then they have like eminent
like cookies with M&Ms and then and
brownies with it like it's like
everything having to do with M&Ms that
you could like yeah they sold out okay
Wow Hershey's consists of her she's just
[ __ ] the candy bar the kisses they
got a nice modest [ __ ] store in Times
Square her she just totally [ __ ] sold
out M&M sorry M&M are they not a part of
the same company we should probably do
our research on that because it might be
like the same company I'm first of all
don't do research in isn't everything
owned by like three different [ __ ]
people that [ __ ] pedophile with his
own goddamn Island he probably owns him
right come on here you can I could roll
with me with the pedophile billionaire
with his own Island gets killed and
burned in hell and then what and they
put him out lighting my fire again that
[ __ ] jackass pretended to kill
himself so he get out of [ __ ] jail oh
no no no there's a worse place for you
anyway so getting back to Times Square
and my store so we're walking by the M&M
store and I'm like what the [ __ ] and
we're just walking and I'm um you're
walking with another buddy of mine and
I'm a few back and I just see this one
this black woman comes up and just
[ __ ] I thought she just pushed you in
the shoulder and what I didn't realize
is she did a half-ass hammer fist that
she that hit the side of your neck she
what I think she was trying to do
actually is that she was trying to hit
me in the face I think she had her palm
open right and she stuck it out and I
think because I turned my head to talk
to our friend or the way that I was
walking she ended up getting me in the
neck but she was just going to hit me in
the face and keep going you know or I
mean I don't know I guess she thought I
know she wanted to fight you so she hit
so she got me in the
and I went what the [ __ ] and I went did
you just hit me and she goes yeah [ __ ]
what [ __ ] what [ __ ]
and just got all of my faith in it no
she didn't what she didn't get in your
face man
you don't remember the bald [ __ ]
jerk-off in between the two of you
before that happened though I was like
did you just hit me
can I tell my [ __ ] story like why am
I on here to listen to you talk about
how you like you know don't like mm okay
I'm the M&M candy that came to life and
got in between you and that [ __ ]
lunatic did you just hit me and she goes
yeah [ __ ] but and I and at first I'm
thinking did I accidentally bump into
her and now she's like upset I like it
then that literally lasted two seconds
and then I got [ __ ] heated and I
started like cursing at her then yes
then you were in between and I don't
even remember what I said to her I was
just like [ __ ] you [ __ ] let's go lower
whatever that whatever it was I said cuz
I did a quick scan of her and I was like
oh she's like 98 pounds soaking wet like
I can I can take her this is this is
easy she had like this blue wig on she
was skinny as a rail I was like I'm
gonna [ __ ] beat this [ __ ] up and
then you were in between us and we're
going back and forth and going back and
forth and then finally I'm like I'm not
actually going to fight this girl like
am I really gonna get into a physical
fight in Times Square and like broad ass
daylight and fight like I'm not gonna
fight this girl I'm a mother like I had
to I had to come back to myself
and remember Who I am and you were
screaming at her and I don't remember
that part I remember this is how I
remember it talking about what's going
on inside of me okay she [ __ ] I was
like what the [ __ ] and then she turned
around and I was like oh [ __ ] so I got
in between the two of you and at first
you were like what the [ __ ] and she's
like what is and then I felt you get mad
and I was like oh no and I could feel
you coming back and in my head I'm
thinking Nia leave leave and then the
two of you I was like the security on a
[ __ ] reality show and she kept
starting to walk away and then you'd say
something and then she come back doing
like in the mock charge like the [ __ ]
elephant beat you up
kick your ass alright I was like let's
go come on [ __ ]
what about I just I don't know I don't
know yes yes yes I was on an episode of
Real Housewives of Times Square he got
me I was so [ __ ] mad I was like how
the how [ __ ] dare you how dare you
and I just got so mad I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna rip this bitch's face
off right and all I'm thinking this is
this is a woman and I can't hit her and
she keeps coming up and that was the
hardest part was when she would do the
mock charge cuz she's so nuts she didn't
even [ __ ] really see me you don't I
mean you know she's so [ __ ] dialed in
on you I had to put my hands up it's
like I can't hit her in the face they're
her titties she [ __ ] way no [ __ ]
nothing
what could I you know where am I
supposed to do find that [ __ ] abdomen
and in her [ __ ] left shoulder so I I
don't know I wish I gotta be honest with
you I kind of wish so mad I wanted to
[ __ ] rip I just wanted to tear her
limb from I know I kind of wish one time
when I pushed her back I accidentally
moisture in the face but Nia you have to
understand that that's you know because
I don't know if you've noticed there was
a bunch of [ __ ] people there just
watch it just beats entertainment they
don't care kids walking around and stuff
and I'm like I can't get into a fight
with this girl in Times Square there's
kids and families and tourists around
you know as soon if we actually had made
contact her and I people would have
brought out their phones and it would
have been a whole [ __ ] thing now that
was not gonna happen here that I was not
gonna allow that I was not gonna let I
just had to be in between the two of you
hoping she was continuing to March and
then I finally realized that she wasn't
gonna leave so then I just barked at her
like a dog your mother your mother to
you your mother your mother no she never
talked to me she was doubt she didn't
see me she was [ __ ] crane then she
said when she watch play that's why your
mother died [ __ ] I was like I'll say
your mother your mother that's why your
mother's dead and I was like oh she's
[ __ ] crazy oh she's just nuts
yeah like she's like on drugs or
something and then that was that was the
end of that's the Times Square
that I remember
I was actually feeling nostalgic in the
middle of all of that well you you know
I hope the Photoshop guy has you with an
Eminem bag and me dressed like taxi
driver getting in between on a reality
shows a lot to work with this week yeah
that was i'ma tell you this I'm very
happy that you that you didn't fight her
and I am very happy that the whole thing
went away but there is a part of me that
wishes I picked her up and body slammed
her into the trash same if you hadn't
for whatever reason got in between us we
would have actually fought because it
was when you got between us and you were
barking it I was like what am i doing
stop and Nia has gotten physical with me
numerous times his relationship and I
could tell you without a doubt unless
that woman had a box cutter she would
have lost that would have been I know
you had your braids right that muttered
how she met if she grabbed you then
that's the equalizer in a chick fight
been hard but I still would have thought
I would have I would still I would think
would have like rammed her like a bull
even if she's grabbing me I would think
that I would just run it towards her and
she you fight dirty
you go dirt oh so dirty I so I would
have been no rules you like bloodsport
yeah I literally at one point our
relationship said Nia if you hit me
again in an argument I'm breaking up
with you do you remember that I do
remember that and you never did it again
although one time you threw my laundry
at me this big anticlimactic because it
was a bunch of socks and you went to
throw them at me and I was too far away
and they got three quarters of the way
and then they just sort of dudududududu
used all that fabric softener I do we
were in the living room with that
[ __ ] apartment we had anyway but our
friend our friend was saying to me he
was like look at you to me yes I went
after her I was like yeah well I can't
actually get into a physical fight with
somebody that's ridiculous
but my adrenaline was going and I was
ready to fight
and then oh this is a greatest part then
oh my god we're leaving where we were
leaving yeah we've gone went to the go
tonight I was going down to open for
Chappelle and the power outage happened
so now we're all walking were walking
through [ __ ] Times Square as
everybody's getting let out of these
shows on the half a Broadway that didn't
that wasn't lit up and we're walking
through and they had to be you know felt
like a million people in Times Square
and who the [ __ ] did we see again the
crazy blue haired lady and I was like
what the [ __ ] is that this now I
actually got a little scared because I'm
like is she stalking me is she waiting
for me like what is really going on but
she was walking through the crowd she
was walking in the opposite direction
she'd even remember it now I guarantee
she didn't remember if I walked up to
her and said hey which way is the subway
she wouldn't she would have no
recollection she was she was completely
out of it and you know my kinder side
wants to be like you know who knows she
if she's living on the street if she's
on drugs who knows what's happened to
her but you know if you come for me
physically like I have no sympathy for
you and I'm going to try to rip your
head off so that started like great
pay-per-view trash talk because you
started cuz you come for me I'm like oh
this is gonna be epic if you come for me
then you know I'm not gonna tolerate
that now I'm gonna say man that's just
like your opinion man just like your
opinion man um yeah well that was that
so I've never in all the years that I
lived here I had never once gotten you
know physically assaulted or attacked or
touched or anything like that that was
the first time it ever happened it was
in Times Square like of all places with
a million people around but she was nuts
and I guess she just saw me and just was
just what happened it's just so funny
that you say in Times Square of all
places because the Times Square that I
remember
oh this old times square with your hos
fur
why do you what'd you just [ __ ] on me
all the time you're supposed to come on
the podcast and show these people how
cool I am that's what you're supposed to
do and you don't [ __ ] do it no I don't
they don't respect me nobody likes me
Hey all right well Nia thank you for
being on the podcast thank you for
having me it's great to be back it's
been a while it has been a while we're
pirates Dale we have other
responsibilities different schedules
yeah I can't just you know do your
podcast on a whim anymore you know
speaking of which I think a little
so-and-so's up I heard her singing in
there
baa baa black sheep she scat sings songs
[Music]
all right I mean let me type in the part
the password here all Billy [ __ ] uh
Billy roadshows adding a show in
Asheville North Carolina at the Thomas
Wolfe Auditorium in the US Cellular
center I'm doing a show on the 11th that
sold out thank you to everybody in and
around Asheville North Carolina so we
are adding another show
October 10th October 12th I'm going to
the [ __ ] Clemson Tigers versus
Florida State Seminoles that's my big
college football game for this year so
second show added thank you to everybody
that is that bought up all those tickets
so goddamn fast and I'm gonna be coming
there with Varzi dude I called it Paul
virzi the Rose Bowl tailgate legend Joe
bartnik
and it's gonna be a it's gonna be
amazing time and then we're gonna go
into Death Valley there's a lot of Death
Valley's in uh in college football isn't
it LSU Clemson lost at university I
can't [ __ ] remember so anyway I got a
read here I got a read here I got a read
here how far into this are we Oh
24 minutes
all right the good boys this is a new
movie what if the guys who made some of
the most outrageous r-rated comedies
like super bed and sausage party decided
to make an r-rated comedy starring
twelve-year-old boys well they did it
and it's the hilarious new movie called
good boys it follows three innocent
sixth graders as they skip school one
day to do whatever it takes to learn how
to kiss before their first middle-school
party
the thing is they get themselves into a
ton of inappropriate and r-rated
situations along the way early audience
audiences and critics have been raving
about good boys saying that you'll laugh
for the 90 minutes straight they're
calling it delightfully inappropriate
wildly raunchy and undeniably sweet
don't forget to go see good boys in
theaters August 16th all right I got
some movies to see here Neal oh yeah the
pendulum swinging back near the social
time out I think is over what are you
talking about you know what I'm talking
about I don't talking about bringing it
back to old school Times Square do you
know how dumb it was for you to bring
that up to me who the hell is that who's
that a picture of um forget it forget it
forget it forget it forget it forget it
forget it
because that half of her face is
gorgeous I don't know about that from
the nose up she looks like me with
braids
what if Bilborough got a tan all right
butcher box I'm kidding butcher box
right now butcher box is offering juicy
flavorful grill ready 100% grass-fed
beef burgers perfect for any summer
cookout butcher box burgers are ready to
go third of a pound patties that can be
simply tossed onto the grill for an easy
weeknight meal or doctored up to create
a show-stopping bacon cheeseburger for
the neighborhood barbecue we all know
that right near
you have company you break out the bacon
absolutely always you're just gonna make
a burger for yourself eat anything
probably only have a bun neighbors are
coming over right that's right you're
trying to kill those [ __ ] because
their musics too loud you invite the
people you don't like
right now new members will get six
burgers for free in every box until
October 15th get summers best offer
before it expires for $20 off your first
box and six burgers for free in every
box all summer long until October 15th
go to butcher box calm / burrow alright
I got a bad feeling they moved up my
[ __ ] call time and there's somebody
[ __ ] hanging outside right now I'm
gonna get a text any second oh where are
you oh dude you look good or less text
message no I did not
what about the email I don't check them
all right let's see what we got here
come on firming
oh wait wait what did I just do here
I'm the worst neo how come I'm not going
to [ __ ] Computers call time
confirming five forty five forty a
pickup it's not 5:40 a.m. it has to be
we [ __ ] wrapped it for all right five
forty okay alright so anyway what else
is there to talk about you have football
season what would you do booty do
football season starts next month with
the NFL preseason Nia are you excited
no I was just crushing what are you
gonna get into I've you know I get into
the Real Housewives you don't I'm
talking about
are you joking right now no I am dead
serious I hang in there when Miranda why
is your shirt completely open now what
is going on cuz I have no time in my
life in a second this is done I gotta
jump in the shower and get ready to
[ __ ] go seduction like you just love
getting undressed no after I do the
reads and I feel like my day is over so
I get a little more comfortable oh I see
okay well just let it all hang out baby
hey I [ __ ] I get into the Real
Housewives I'll sit down and watch those
[ __ ] I swear to God I will punch you
in the face again what are you talking
about you have violence she gets with me
[Music]
by the way can we just go back and talk
about your little remark about I've been
physical with you in the past
hey there's really no need for you to
bring that up okay this is the shame
you're embarrassed by your behavior no
you just did that to like throw me under
the bus and be like let's put it in
perspective okay I wasn't whaling on you
I wasn't like being like it was at most
a shove okay when I was pissed off of
you liar you punched me the face of
Valentine's Day was a jab it was a jab I
don't remember but haha President Trump
are you saying you don't recall do you
ever say that to me I did not punch you
in the face though I don't think I
punched you in the face I feel like I
threw something at you you did that too
yeah yeah I know I've done that a couple
times this was all put under the the the
umbrella of passionate person I'm a
passionate person I get that from my mom
my dad told me my mom used to throw
things - I think she did for a while but
anyway um yeah but don't make it seem
like you know every time I got mad at
you I like pops you or something like
let's not paint that picture okay I
don't need another [ __ ] reddit thread
about me why are they so mean to you why
do you think
[Laughter]
[Music]
certain radio show that's no longer on
the air you know are they still left uh
yeah I think those people who used to
enjoy you on that radio show that is no
longer on the air you know that radio
show attracted a certain kind of person
it wasn't all of them it was a lot of
them and you know so they're still
hanging in there with you because
they're fans you know those people
there's some of the toughest people on
the internet near oh they really are
tough and you get them a keyboard Nia
and they will say things and they have a
problem with somebody like me being with
somebody like you who gives a [ __ ] now
gives a [ __ ] now all you're doing is you
just [ __ ] you
you're just making their [ __ ] day
theirs they sit there type in their
little things this another thing - Nia
you should see the [ __ ] people say about
me I don't even read it like I kind of
stopped about a year ago like you can't
read most of it it's a [ __ ] really I
don't know it isn't a a it's not a good
gauge of what people are thinking
because more times than not I think half
the time they don't even mean it they're
just going for a laugh and if you're if
you're in a bad mood you're gonna take
it a particular way but it does get old
my favorite is the the internet
compliment is always it's just like you
know like hey your last special suck but
this one was great like that's that's a
compliment yeah it's like one of those
those things like the end of this it's
just so like like it always has to be
about them and their perspective on
something it's I have to be honest with
you dude I really [ __ ] think that the
noose the new celebrities the new
celebrities are regular people as far as
stereotypical just rude behavior and
they all of them act like how like
[ __ ] celebrities acted in the 90s
when you could actually get away with
being a douche I'm not saying
celebrities act better now because
they're better people it's just she
can't get away with it anymore because
everybody's got like a [ __ ] cell
phone camera
recorded which they did do a few people
so now like there's a certain level of
decency you got to behave not saying
that better but these [ __ ] [ __ ] on
the internet they can act however they
want to act and nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah
this shirt is completely off because I
have to get in the [ __ ] shower huh
yeah I got I wrapped it for in the
[ __ ] morning
yeah wrapped at 4:00 in the morning woke
up had breakfast ah no no you weren't
you was sleeping like an angel it's hard
to believe someone so violent could
sleep so peacefully stop it what are you
doing
first of all Nia everybody took it as a
joke but now you've gone on the
defensive as this you have something to
hide and what you've done is pour gas on
the fire and you've created extra work
for your publicist and as your publicist
what I'm telling you now is you need to
get out in front of this and you need to
apologize right now
you need to get out in front of this and
you need to apologize on this episode
for making light of some of your past
behavior we have what we need from you
is we need you take your past behavior
seriously I sincerely apologize for all
past behaviors that are included
violence of any sort I have grown up
tremendously since then I regret it
immensely
she apologized today on the podcast but
what was really lacking in the apology
was anything directed towards the person
she did the violence to now this is a
classic example who was my boyfriend at
the time knocking him down clarifying my
husband now bill burr is is he's a human
being first we don't need to put labels
on him I was like 25 years so easy this
is that don't like I didn't deserve it
yeah do you remember what I said that
made you that made you punch me in the
face
I don't actually what are you doing you
know member I remember I said Nia I love
you and I want you to be my wife
and you was so offended you were like I
said I wanted something casual you
wanted something casual yeah remember I
did kind of want something casual you
didn't you always trying to act like you
with this [ __ ] hey man I just came
into town you know like you were this
drifter I just wanted to date I wasn't
trying again it's like well that may not
be true I mean I want it to be like with
someone who would actually take me on
dates and things like that I was tired
of like just hanging out hey let's hang
out let's just meet up up a bike I want
it to be like you know in a dating
situation yeah I think we're saying the
same thing okay
and then you cuted your way into the
apartment what a mean cuted my way you
invited me
no I'm saying how you ended up living
with me see my might you would do that I
was there all the time right and you
started saying you wanted to move in and
I wasn't ready so I stay here for a
month that's what it was
and I just kept going this is my
apartment you'd be like and it was funny
and you kept doing it and then one day
you did move in yeah and like the night
before I had like the whole u-haul set
up and everything you really gonna move
I'm ready and I'm like the [ __ ] you
all's gonna be here at 8:00 a.m. so and
look at us now
I know I almost made a huge mistake cuz
I almost I almost I was freaking out I
almost didn't let you move in really
well that would have been the end of the
relationship I think cuz it's like what
are we doing once you got a u-haul you
make the u-haul go back empty hole
that's that's not a good thing DeRosa
was the one who talked me off the ledge
really they just were there I just
[ __ ] let him move in that went all
right is that right that's all it was
thanks Jill Joey Rosa's bringing the
sunshine all right I gotta go jump in
the shower
thank you for listening Ania I
appreciate after all these years you
know unlike Tina I could actually
forgive my abuser it's not the same it's
not the same
I wasn't beating you okay that's not
what happened there was only because I
took some self-defense classes maybe two
incidences when I got really heated and
control okay
stop lying it's not it's not a good
thing okay so let's just leave it at
that
just a little more - and yet you
continue to just like be yourself and
like I am supposed to not I'm just
supposed to sit there and be like
there's no funny comedian like oh you
know he's an artist a temperamental
artist like huh that's how it goes you
know these comics yeah it's funny you
literally just gave me [ __ ] for being
myself that's all that's a classic
[ __ ] woman thing how dare you be
yourself in this relationship as you get
to be your best self you're a female
Gemini male Gemini's are the worst of
the worst
says who female Gemini's yeah this
female Gemini it's such that astrology
[ __ ] is it's just like there's a
brilliance to you obviously but then
you're completely like out of your mind
this is just in a more Internet
compliments Kanye West is the Gemini the
[ __ ] 45 as a Gemini who else who else
Nia who else so is everybody born in
April a mass-murdering psychopath
because Hitler was born in April April
Fool's Day right
no for 20 men friend in college never
mind
I thought for some reason you had the
same birthday as Hitler he had he had a
different sign - I think you did
I don't know I just know that Gemini men
are [ __ ] nuts
based on what me I mean yeah a lot of my
research I mean no but you need you need
you need you can't take down every guy
in June because of me not every guy but
I mean I don't know let's see how many
let's see how many women wait a second
well obviously they're gonna all you
guys do is [ __ ] [ __ ] and try to
change the person you're with because
you don't want to face your own [ __ ]
[ __ ]
because you don't want to face your own
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's what that is
guilty as charged
guilty as charged guilty as charged
you're right you're absolutely right now
let me ask you this let me ask you this
watch this watch this [ __ ] 180 flip
everybody watch this watch this no no
his his - because you know what's coming
no you know what's coming okay what are
you gonna admit to in terms of what
exactly
thank you I rest my case that is a woman
right there well man what the [ __ ] was
what the [ __ ] is it again I gotta
[ __ ] work on all of this [ __ ] and
you're sitting here like you're done
they're having the ribbon-cutting
ceremony then there it is perfectly okay
famous people Gemini up let's go let's
go Fame yeah yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna find five but mr. Rogers was
born at you all right Clint Eastwood you
got a problem with him Peter Dinklage a
little person go ahead 2019 make fun of
him I mean he's a great actor Chris
Pratt solid Richard Madden Raphael Nadel
tennis pro he's a gentleman he's out
there playing tennis Boris Johnson
whoever the [ __ ] this
oh boy Donald Trump okay there's a big
strike Kayden Bosch no cool no clue
all right so you got me and Trump Peter
Dinklage they could to give him a better
[ __ ] picture he looks crazy
he's [ __ ] raised by wolves would you
get off of my computer
Tupac he was also [ __ ] crazy though he
was a genius and amazing B was [ __ ]
crazy John F Kennedy Johnny Depp Kanye
West stellan skarsgård Adam West min
Muhammad salat the pilot masala the
[ __ ] best soccer playing the ball
Anderson Cooper you don't get any more
[ __ ] PC than that guy right Bob Dylan
George the fifth Mike Wahlberg Paul
McCartney the happy Beatle Che Guevara
mm-hmm
Lenny Kravitz me what is your [ __ ]
problem with you Liam Neeson John Wayne
George HW Ted Kaczynski Michael J Fox
[ __ ] you the guy who played [ __ ]
Aquaman all right me all right [ __ ] you
all right famous women born in Illinois
no
Gemini let's see what we got here see so
Marilyn Monroe out of her [ __ ] mind
out of her [ __ ] mind
[Laughter]
27 famous celebrity Gemini women all
right here we go out of her mind out of
her mind no clue but she looks like
she's nuts crazy throwing phones at
people she's nuts
oh she's a queer just like you she
[ __ ] throw [ __ ] Patti LaBelle's cool
Octavia Spencer she's awesome
Aly Reisman Lauryn Hill turning 44
that's the 21 year old who's waiting for
her to go on [ __ ] stage crazy I'm not
saying she's crazy I don't wanna say
these people Brooke Shields Heidi Klum
Alanis Morissette there you go there's
crazy people in every month
yes Felicia Rashad give it to me Paula
Abdul icon keep going keep going I love
this you had Ted Kaczynski on your list
and Donald Trump well listen guys do
stuff you know all the way what do you
want for me all right swell listen okay
well you know something that the
internet existed when you met me you
could have googled that and you didn't
so I'm blaming you
you know what I love that so you just
get to be you in the relationship yeah
god forbid a guy does that holy [ __ ] all
right ladies and gentlemen and I'm gonna
show you so you [ __ ] no I'm [ __ ] no
you know what it is near I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] cool and I support you you're
[ __ ] cool I am thank you yes so stop
lumping me in with the Ted Kaczynski's
and Donald Trump of this month okay I am
every bit as valid as the Olsen twins
[Music]
this has been an example of how to stick
up for yourself
no it isn't it's just a [ __ ] complete
waste of an argument all right there
sports bra did you alright that's it
enjoy the music
and I've throwback Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and shout out to that purple
haired woman blue haired woman you know
Times Square hey you know what maybe I
gave her a little bit of money to give
you a taste of your own medicine what
the [ __ ] you've been doing to me spoken
just like a Gemini in other words you
were on the positive side if your sign
alright and with that thank God you know
Hitler used to [ __ ] go by astrology
yeah that's why he [ __ ] lost the war
cuz rather than going but yeah you had a
he was a [ __ ] he was never higher
than a [ __ ] private in the [ __ ]
army and he's looking at the goddamn
stars to decide if he should start a
[ __ ] war on two fronts the dumb [ __ ]
he had like all these [ __ ] people
that don't cuff idiot [ __ ] [ __ ] um
anyways but thank God he was I wasn't
trying to leak it sound like I'm [ __ ]
pissed that my team lost and with that
it was more me ranting about astrology
listen to the music and enjoy the
[ __ ]
we have another bonus episode of
greatest hits there's the opportunity
[Music]
to
hey what's going on it's bill Birds the
Monday morning podcast for Monday July
25th 2011 how you guys doing I hope you
had a hope you had a great week like I
did I was I was down in Irvine I got one
more show tonight taping this on a
Sunday I got one more show down there in
Irvine both shows were sold out last
night
Saturday night and Friday night they
were just about full and I just want to
thank everyone for coming down there you
know that's a very difficult Club to
sell out as a white boy as a whitey as a
cracker
as a peckerwood it's a very it's very
difficult you know people you know for
years I tried to I tried to go down
there and they they don't nobody comes
to see white guys down here they only
come to see Latinos or famous white guys
and so finally or if you put out [ __ ]
you know four or five hours of material
and you're consistently funny
they finally show up which they did and
I was beyond excited and I want to thank
everyone for coming down and you know
this is something I have not been able
to enjoy since I moved out here like
when I lived in New York City I'd gotten
to the point where I could sell out a
club in New York which was great
I got the feeling of selling out a club
and then I could sleep in my own bed
and haven't had that out here because
because I'm a green go and I was able to
finally crack through so I'm psyched
beyond psyched you know now if I could
just do something about that two hours
of traffic I got to sit in that's the
only thing that sucks driving down to
Irvine two hours of traffic do you
understand that you understand how long
that is
two hours people one-way two hours you
could fly from here Los Angeles to
[ __ ] Denver Colorado in two hours we
got it built and we also understand that
a jet is a lot faster than a car all
right go [ __ ] yourselves but anyways it
was a great week
and I want to thank everyone for coming
down and considering I'm in such a
gracious mood this week why don't we
continue the congratulations with big
congratulations to all those alligator
wrestling beer drinking maniacs whatever
other stereotypical [ __ ] cuz I don't
know anything about your country
Australians
congratulations to the country of
Australia the first Aussie Cadel Evans
ever to win the Tour de France you know
congratulations I remember that feeling
the first time Greg LeMond wanted in the
80s it was awesome because we had never
wanted up to that point as far as I know
and I was just great to see you know you
know it's good to win something
everybody doesn't think he can win after
a while and you know and I hope that
they don't try to figure out whether
Cadell was on drugs and [ __ ] with your
enjoyment of it 10 years later like
they're doing with Lance Armstrong just
because they hate America and that
really is the reason all right the guy
passed nine thousand [ __ ] drug tests
you know you couldn't get him he was he
was the Teflon dog that's your fault
French people maybe if you took you
goddamn braise off and you worked a
little bit harder you would have caught
him how bad the fact that you guys
wanted to catch him that [ __ ] bad and
you couldn't go [ __ ] yourself and I'm
supposed to what believe his dirty
teammate who tested positive the guy who
robbed a bank is now going well even
though he didn't catch this guy robbing
a bank he actually robbed a bank at the
[ __ ] out of here and if he was on drugs
so were the other nine guys behind him
who only lost by 90 seconds give me a
[ __ ] break all right certain sports
need drugs
all right and it's basically every sport
that is played at a professional level
beyond the age of 23 beyond the age of
23 you can't run around you just can't
do it
you know anybody anybody like 27 go out
and go play flag football out of [ __ ]
nowhere and you can't you're in traction
for like the next three weeks can you
imagine doing that at a pro level and
they can tackle there's no way to
that without drugs I am totally 100% Pro
drugs I don't think they hurt the game
I think they enhance it I think you take
awesome athletes and they'd become even
better you know and I also think as much
as all these people are [ __ ] whining
about them that eventually they're gonna
seep their way into regular society and
then when I'm in my 80s I'm gonna be on
roids nice safe roids because of the
sacrifices that these heroes made Lance
Armstrong is a hero he is a [ __ ]
hundred seventy pound lab rat all right
he let all that [ __ ] be pumped into him
for the betterment of us and the glory
and all the French [ __ ] he could have
but getting back to me you wait all
these [ __ ] out there I'm
telling you all these people dumping
that Rogaine on their head and poisoning
their brains
every year they they refine that [ __ ]
they make it a little more pure you know
it's like look at weed man weed is
[ __ ] unreal now out here because it's
because it's legal the [ __ ] they can
make you high but not sleepy
what do you wanna do you want to focus
here you go smoke this [ __ ] you want to
just sit there and and just veg out or
you want to go to sleep they got weed
for everything now they couldn't do that
[ __ ] back in the 70s they pulled it out
of the ground and you rolled it up with
a [ __ ] newspaper so I want to thank
all these people all these people
getting their head scalped right taking
propecia I don't like the fact that I'm
going bald but I'm letting you guys go
on point let you guys [ __ ] with your
systems and figure out what's safe and
then you wait one day when I'm 80 I'm
gonna a full head of jet-black hair and
I'm gonna have [ __ ] pecs and I won't
be able to run a 440 and ride a bike up
the Pyrenees Mountains for a month
straight because of the sacrifices that
these [ __ ] heroes these misunderstood
heroes are making god bless them god
bless them all and congratulations to
Australia that's that's [ __ ] huge
that's really huge you know that'll do
wonders for cycling and you know
maybe you guys can broaden your horizons
stop listening to Yahoo serious and
drinking that stupid Foster's lager that
comes in that beer can the size of a
depth charge in World War two do you
know that's one of their shittiest beers
everybody everybody here in the States
no one no one down under drinks that
[ __ ] that's one of the first things that
I learned when I went there for four
days I walked into about 20 pubs and I
didn't see one Australian person
drinking that vat of goose piss I got to
be honest with you I don't even know
what I don't even want to taste like
it's got to taste like [ __ ] if they give
you so much you know what I mean I think
that that's the big thing they go in
quantity over quality and you know
there's Australian people down there
there they don't give a [ __ ] so they're
not drinking it they don't care so what
do they do ask [ __ ] who's gullible
enough to drink this [ __ ] goose piss
I will send it to the States it's
perfect
they don't know anything about other
countries we'll just make up a big lie
we'll make it macho you Aussies you guys
ever see the stupid Fosters lagers
larger commercials that they show out
here they're like they go I can't
remember how the [ __ ] it went cell phone
be yeah that's what they would do and
you guys would have some sort of like
the most macho cell phone ever which is
basically you you whisper a phone
conversation into a woman's ear slap her
across the face and said [ __ ] go tell
it to my friend across town maybe like
cell phone and then neither be like BIA
and then it'd be this giant beer can
it's the whole [ __ ] thing who's got a
bigger dick and evidently from what I've
heard it tastes like piss that's what
I've heard
but anyway so let's plow ahead this is
the Monday morning podcast everybody if
you're new to my podcast as I see my
podcast listener ship growing with with
each week I want to thank you for for
coming along if you want to send me any
sort of questions we I answer questions
on this if you want some advice just to
let you know in case you you know been
listening to this podcast at this point
you haven't been able to figure out that
I am NOT
college-educated technically I am so
don't take anything I say seriously
you're on your own if you take my advice
you're on my you're on your own all
right but anything you want to do
overrated under Raiders underrated the
email is bill at the mm podcast.com
sorry had a big breakfast went out to a
[ __ ] a breakfast place and you know
I'm doing this whole thing man it's
unbelievable where I'm just eating well
and I don't have to go to the gym
anymore it's awesome absolutely
phenomenal
so ate like [ __ ] last night so today I
go out to breakfast I take Nia out and I
[ __ ] we go out we go out for breakfast
and they're all ordering all this yummy
stuff and it came around to me I'm like
I'm gonna do the right thing
I ordered granola and what do they end
up doing they and then it bring me this
vat of green I said you could get
bananas or chocolate or bananas and
chocolate extra which totally defeats
the purpose of eating healthy if you get
the chocolate so I go let me get the
bananas and then they come back like 15
20 minutes later I'm sorry we had a
bananas they don't even wear bananas I
just realized everybody's gonna be like
you got bananas on your granola what do
you yes people I know my own material
all right so she's like we're out of
bananas I'm sorry you want some fresh
berries I was like absolutely put them
on there sweetheart
anything you can do to bring me a bowl
of [ __ ] granola within a half-hour do
you think he can do that I basically
ordered a bowl of cereal in its 20
minutes later and I'm still waiting for
it okay I know I know you're on this
side of the counter you can't make him
work faster
so anyways they bring the stuff over and
they bring in this giant goddamn
medieval [ __ ] soup bowl and it did
completely defeated the purpose of
eating healthy you know I guess I could
have just ate eaten half the bowl but
you know I come from that you know waste
not want not you finish what you eat
I have to tell you guys that [ __ ] my
parents used to do this thing my parents
were strict how strict were they they
were so strict that when I was a kid if
you didn't finish your dinner
they wrapped it in plastic and they made
you eat it for breakfast yes they did
what do you think about that you timeout
generation [ __ ] you guys probably
have a 1-800 number you could call 1-800
my mommy's being mean that you could
call and get out of that [ __ ] well
that's not out went down back in the 70s
it was [ __ ] horrific you felt good
when you tapped out cuz you didn't want
to eat whatever gross thing you know you
didn't feel like eating but then you
would just go to bed like stressin like
some guy working on Wall Street knowing
that you were gonna wake up and the rest
of the family was gonna be eating
waffles and you're gonna be sitting
there eating cold cube steaks and green
bean casserole oh yeah cube steaks were
the worst fish was bad what else
I was brutal ice [ __ ] cold you'd be
sitting there eating cube steaks and
that [ __ ] was already hard to chew when
it was when it was heated up forget
about when it was cold
oh so Larry should be sitting there
looking like Kurt Gibson in the seventh
inning big [ __ ] wad of it and you
goddamn chin your cheek I'm sorry you
know but uh you know I don't even think
it even worked after a while they they
realized it didn't even work it just you
know at some point the kid just doesn't
want to eat it and I know I got some
funny stories about if you ever come out
live to one of my live shows you want to
hear the cube steak story just you just
yell it out just wait towards the other
end of my act alright and just say just
yell out cube steak and I'll tell you
this story some of the stories I I know
I don't wanna put them out on the
internet but I'll tell him in a club who
gives a [ __ ] the [ __ ] was I talking
about I got totally sidetracked I was
talking about Aussies and their big
stupid bear now gives a [ __ ] right
that's how I do the podcast if I can't
[ __ ] remember it it wasn't important
or maybe you just dumb bill um speaking
of dumb there's a number number of
people who for some [ __ ] reason are
having difficulty finding my podcast
despite the fact that if you google
search the Monday morning podcasts the
first thing that comes up is the fan
page alright
it's WWE mm podcast com
I think you guys ago in WWE mm podcast
it's the MM podcast like the Ohio State
University
how great is it that they finally
punished those cheating bastards you
know can you believe that selling your
own [ __ ] Jersey Jesus Christ burn the
whole program down that's another thing
I think is absolutely [ __ ] stupid
then policing you know if you got a
police college football players you
should [ __ ] pay him all right because
of what they're doing you you you you're
selling a hundred thousand tickets a
week hundred thousand people packet
understand to watch people who aren't
getting paid who on any play there dream
of going to the NFL could end and I
don't want to hear you [ __ ]
conservative [ __ ] go will they get a
free education no they don't they get
one in football
oh you tough guys out there you think
that you could learn that playbook play
at a Division one level travel what they
travel be in the shape that they have to
be in and major in like [ __ ] biology
give me a goddamn break
something has to give all right and if
you have the potential to go to the NFL
that's what you should be majoring in
the thing that's gonna make you a
multi-millionaire and just have a bunch
of [ __ ] running at your dick that's
what you focus on okay so I think if
you're gonna give these kids [ __ ] and
tell them not to sell their jerseys you
ought to give them some sort of stipend
some sort of something okay you can't
have some superstar kid
he's gonna win the heisman trophy he's
that they're building a brand new wing
on one of the dorms because of what this
[ __ ] kid does over four years and his
mother needs a kidney transplant and he
can't even sell his [ __ ] Jersey to
get a free tattoo there the whole thing
is it's it's [ __ ] stupid all right
if I had the money I'd be a booster I'd
love to do that showed up at 75 Eldorado
at the Longhorn [ __ ] horns right on
the hood chomping on a cigar just coming
up there and [ __ ] paying players
that's gotta be awesome
knowing that you it was your bag of cash
that got that debt four star running
back flying down the field everybody's
patting you on the back
you and your trophy wife it's got our
hand on your package there's no love in
the relationship you don't need any
you've filled up with the sound of a
hundred thousand people going crazy
because of some [ __ ] that you made
happen with your dirty filthy oil money
I want to be that guide my next
generation next generation my next life
when I come around again I wonder what
year it's gonna be when I come around
again you know because I think when you
die I think you go right into the mud
you know and then that's it and then no
no you either turn into a fossil fuel or
you become a mosquito or maybe like some
sort of organism that lives in the belly
of a cow right that's why I think being
a human being is what you hit the
[ __ ] lottery you know you hit the
[ __ ] lottery you got thumbs you live
in the life sometimes I think I wouldn't
mind being an ape though you know I
always like doing pull-ups though
there's no [ __ ] way you know I always
stunk swinging on the jungle gym I think
it would be great to be like a gorilla
back in a day being a gorilla like 200
years ago
I wonder if gorillas knew if they knew
then what they know now about people or
animals in general what what are they
had done do you think they would have
joined forces
and just [ __ ] wipe this out when
there was only a couple thousand of us
on the planet have [ __ ] stupid
animals they had that chance
that's what you get if you [ __ ] wake
up next time you know why don't you once
you learn you want to talk about
cheating
you know performance-enhancing weapons
the second we picked up a stick we we
were [ __ ] cheating you know Tiger
doesn't come at you with the stick Tiger
just comes at you all natural what do we
do we got a [ __ ] bazooka
we got machine guns stick them in a cage
we drugged them I'm on both sides of
this argument
alright let's plow ahead here what did I
want to talk about this week how far are
we in this we're about 18 minutes in you
want to go with some advice right right
right out of the gate let's go in for
the Wisco with some advice bill I need
some serious advice on what to do with
the relationship the relationship I was
in I just broke it off yesterday but I
need some [ __ ] reassurance
reassurance Jesus I couldn't get through
that word could I all right I'm 19 and I
mean this girl had been dating for three
and a half years basically since I was
16 my girlfriend and I have always
gotten along and [ __ ] was really great
almost too great up until the last year
it dawned on me nearly overnight my life
was stagnant I did the same repetitive
[ __ ] with her over and over every night
it hit me really hard I felt as if I
were a married man at the age of 19 void
of all my piss and vinegar vinegar it
pissed me the [ __ ] off even the sex got
old and I feel like a spoiled prick for
writing that because I know a lot of
guys out there would get a left nut to
get their dick wet Jesus but you can't
eat steak every night jeez because this
guy throw more cliches in there over the
last past few years I slowly but surely
moved away from old chicks of friends I
used to be friendly with in high school
until the other day I [ __ ] realized
that I really don't have much left I
feel as if I have one true friend
sprinkled in with a
use opportunistic pricks I call friends
I'm not happy with who I call my friends
anymore
my gut tells me that the reason I've
lost friends is because of being too
heavily invested with my girlfriend now
I seem to be left with just her I broke
it off yesterday thinking to myself that
there's more to [ __ ] life at the age
of 19 than getting the same limp-dick
[ __ ] every night it broke her heart
when I told her I wasn't happy anymore I
want to get back out there have a social
life reconnect with some friends meet
some new people and get some [ __ ] she
still keeps trying to text me and call
me just to talk and still wants to be
friends but she's the clingy type and I
think she wants to weasel back in my
question is did I make the right move do
I still talk to this girl as a friend or
do I cut it clean any reassurance or
advice or possibly a 5 minute rant would
do me wonders alright yeah it sucks it
sucks you know sometimes you got to hurt
somebody but this basically is your
first relationship and what happened to
you happens to most people women
included you kind of lose yourself in it
you do you not live in a balanced life
see you could have been with that girl
and still had your old friends and
aquaintances if you worked on that but I
think you got head over heels with this
girl and you kind of went down the
[ __ ] rabbit hole
and then all of a sudden you turned
around there was no one behind you and
that kind of freaked you out which is
totally normal at 19 so I don't think
you're doing anything wrong as far as
maintaining a relationship with her
maybe later my gut says don't do it now
you're just gonna hurt her more because
it's gonna give her hope that you're
gonna get back with her or you're gonna
have that awful after you broke up sex
where you're gonna be oh I'm psyched I'm
getting laid and halfway through it I
swear to god you have an 80% chance
she's gonna start crying okay at which
point you'll be like oh my god is this
like a rape case now what's going on and
it's you're gonna pull out
blue balls she's gonna be crying and
you're gonna be like sorry and then
you're gonna comfort her but not comfort
it too much to give her hope and you're
gonna [ __ ] walk out to your car at a
45-degree angle feeling like your balls
are down on the on on by your ankles so
stay away from that um yeah I think if
you guys are gonna be friends I just
think that sometime needs to go because
it's not fair to her cuz you sound
definitely like you don't want to be
with her anymore
and every time you talk to her even if
you say I still want to get with you
you're just putting her right back at
the start line of getting over you and
moving on with her life or whatever the
hell's gonna happen and that's not fair
to her so you know and you did the right
thing you wanted to be out of it so you
got out of it that's exactly what you
got to do you got to hurt somebody
sometimes it's much worse to waste their
life it's way worse and you're only 19
you guys you guys heal fast you'll get
over it so get out there have a good
time
wear a [ __ ] condom always get
yourself uh get yourself some new
friends football seasons coming up did
they work it out by the way I don't even
really I don't even know I just keep
looking at the keep looking at the
ticker by the way how selfish were the
[ __ ] owners in this by the way
speaking of all you people who call it
those sports radio shows and you don't
even know what you're talking about you
just immediately start trashing the
athletes because you can put a face to
him they're not the bad guys in this one
they signed an agreement in 2006 and the
owners had their lawyers look at it and
the owners agreed to it and in five
years later they're like oh we don't
make good enough money so what do they
do they just lock him out which is the
owners they just basically took their
stadiums and they went home and they
basically said to the players we want
all of you to take an eighteen percent
pay cut and play two extra games you
know what the [ __ ] do you think the
players are gonna do
alright so it's not over yet lockout
nearing an end camps could open Saturday
ladies and gentlemen hona there I'm just
gonna watch college football I don't
give a [ __ ]
they are the Bama Crimson
playing the Wolverines of Michigan whoa
Nelly we got a barnburner they're gonna
be swapping paint this Saturday night
[Music]
Michigan's got it I'll watch that [ __ ]
Keith Jackson still killing him at like
[ __ ] 83 years of age is Labor peace
just around the corner for the NFL
according to ESPN report the NFL Players
Association and league have reached an
agreement on the remaining points in a
proposed ten-year collective bargaining
agreement the report citing unnamed
sources all right so go [ __ ] yourself
right there I tap them okay you know we
can't confirm it the kick and I and it's
unnamed source would you like to
continue reading this no I wouldn't no I
would not so anyways let me get back to
the [ __ ] questions here so oh this is
something I wanted to bring up you know
I sometimes I forget how old I am
because I still feel like I'm [ __ ] 18
is you know when I do that [ __ ] you know
whenever I took bring up a female I
walked into the store and all of a
sudden there was this [ __ ] lady you
know I do that lady I thought you guys
all knew that that that was a little
tribute to Jerry Lewis but I forgot that
there's a lot of young people in their
20s
college students listening to this [ __ ]
that's Jerry Lewis that isn't me all
right
and I actually that was like his
catchphrase he'd go hey lady I can't
even do it and it was the funniest [ __ ]
ever and the fact that my mother thought
it was so stupid it made it even funnier
there's nothing better than watching a
Jerry Lewis movie with my mother with an
earshot but anyway so I actually went on
YouTube and I got a couple of Jerry
Lewis YouTube videos this week and I was
trying to find one a clip if anybody can
find one of him saying hey lady I can't
find one I don't know if they took them
all down but there's this guy doing a
tribute to Jerry Lewis and he's
imitating Jerry Lewis while singing
Kenny Rogers that Kenny Rogers song lady
which
familiar with it because you're a
youngster the song basically it's this
romantic song like lady you're mine I
love you and the course is later your
eyes are the only what I need but he's
doing it as Jerry Lewis so he's going
lady wow I can't even [ __ ] do it but
it's it's really obnoxious and if you're
Jerry Lewis fan I found it to be [ __ ]
hilarious I'm not saying it's the
greatest impression but it's [ __ ]
funny as hell and then for everyone out
there you know a lot of people in
America always trashed the French like I
did earlier making fun of their Berets
I'm not really you know one of them one
of my bucket list things is actually go
to the Tour de France in one of those
cities you know where they go through
and all of a sudden there's like a
castle from the 1300s who the [ __ ] would
want to do that on a sunny day sitting
out in a cafe getting treated like [ __ ]
by some Frenchman right cuz you're
rosetta stone [ __ ] isn't holding up
eating a couple of [ __ ] I don't know
what the hell you eat over there some
pastries and all of a sudden all these
athletes come flying by and their bikes
I just think that would be amazing
follow it around for a few days you know
save up some euros bring them back to
America in case the [ __ ] dollar
crashes which it might next month who
knows I want to I wanted to do that so
but anyways one of the things is is this
country has always made fun of the
French or has at least in my lifetime
and one of the things that they make fun
of them of they make fun of them because
they think Jerry Lewis they're huge fans
of Jerry Lewis and think he's a genius
I've heard a bunch of people you know
people that I respected make fun of them
for that kind of like you know how the
Germans think David Hasselhoff is that
there's a rockstar
I got a coast I got a cosine with
Americans on that one I don't know what
the [ __ ] you guys are listening to over
there but maybe cuz it's a second
language maybe like his permed mullet I
don't know what it is but I'll sign off
if you want to make fun of Germans for
me
in front of that but I think their cars
offset the quality of their cars offset
the fact maybe that's why they like
David Hasselhoff they're so far beyond
everybody you know scientifically you
know you know we stole all their secrets
after World War Two you realize that
half of our Rockets audio tape the whole
space [ __ ] program our missile
program all of them we took a bunch of
German scientists from them and we were
like show us how how you did all that
stuff that you were doing to us in the
war yes so maybe they're so focused on
that making cars that go like 200 miles
an hour and subtly drop down half an
inch just in case there's a steel beam
hanging across the highway we can't do
that here in America we don't know how
to do that [ __ ] so I guess you know
you're so busy looking at that egghead
[ __ ] that when you leave the lab you
know you just don't want to think see
put on a little bit of Hasselhoff you
know what does he think about the beach
in his chest hair going out and finding
a [ __ ] the right medallion to wear
around his neck but anyways they've
always made fun of the French for
thinking Jerry Lewis was a genius and I
got to tell you something the French are
100% right when they say Jerry Lewis is
a genius and if you don't believe me
YouTube video of the week this is one of
the classics you're ever gonna see in
comedy it's this just it's called the
movies called the errand boy from 1961
Jerry Lewis plays an errand boy and
there's a scene where he walks into one
of the big shots office it's empty
there's nobody in there and he looks
around and decides to sit down at the
big conference table he lights up a
cigar and starts acting like he's
running the [ __ ] company and they
basically play this Count Basie song
underneath it and he pantomimes the
entire scene he doesn't say one [ __ ]
word this clip is 50 years old and it
had me and Nia on the ground laughing
it's like
it's such [ __ ] genius I can't even
explain it now some people with like oh
he's just making a bunch of faces just
watch his movements with the music and
out every time he turns around and every
time it's like a new section and in the
music he spins around in the chair at
the whole the way he comes out of it I
swear to god it's so [ __ ] perfect it
as a comedian it almost it almost brings
tears to your eyes
it's absolute genius and I challenge any
of you [ __ ] to watch this and
tell me that it isn't alright so now
that I trashed the French at the
beginning of this podcast I okay for
their merciless stalking
I just realized halfway through it I
don't even know if it's the French who
were investigating them well [ __ ] you
what's going on in your country their
merciless stalking of Lance Armstrong
okay
now I'm telling you you got it right you
got it wrong with Lance you got it right
with Jerry Lewis okay I don't have any
problem with the French Open I love that
you play on clay I think you country is
absolutely beautiful I think you need to
drop the attitudes
oh you know what I think it is I think
you guys are a little [ __ ] insecure
what's the matter you used to be running
[ __ ] when you had that [ __ ] sawed-off
little runt running around rubbing his
[ __ ] stomach what he had done since
then
exactly John you know you guys alike you
like you like the [ __ ] Beach Boys and
then too 70s from like 1970 till they
had that hit again in 1988 that those
are the years Francis in right now so
you know whatever the Beach Boys had
like that last hit in like 68 or 69 then
they had nothing for like 20 [ __ ]
years that's what the French are like
they had Napoleon you know he was one of
the few [ __ ] [ __ ] white acts that
could also go on Soul Train and kill it
you know and then he got his ass beaten
back all the way to France and ever
since then he hasn't had a hit
you realize that French you guys haven't
had a hit going out [ __ ] two decades
the goddamn Phillies have won two World
Series since you last had a [ __ ] hit
that's saying something because those
sons of [ __ ] are averaging about one
every sixty years do you understand that
I hope you do come on you bilingual [ __ ]
um so they bring you guys really smoke
your cigarettes holding it underneath
you know like you're you're [ __ ] the
undercarriage the undercarriage of the
cigarettes you really sit there with
your striped shirts on your little
moustaches you don't do you please tell
me a dump so anyways the errand boy 1969
Jerry Lewis please watch that and we
actually have another clip from that
where he does another scene where he he
has to watch some phones he can't figure
out which phone is ringing and I you
know I don't think that people not like
Jim Carrey I think could do it
I actually I don't know the guy is an
absolute [ __ ] genius he's one of my
favorites and do you know he actually
spoke at my graduation I know a lot of
you guys probably think that's [ __ ]
I swear to god he did and in the morning
they had a parent students breakfast the
day of graduation and then on graduation
night you know there was the graduation
so or afternoon they had the so in the
morning Jerry Lewis spoke at the
breakfast and he was crazy Jerry and he
was a [ __ ] riot and he killed and me
and my dad will laughing our asses off
and you know my mom she's just not a fan
but I still think she liked it but it
was really awesome and then when he
spoke at our graduation he then he
became like telethon Jerry he actually
as always he made the transition he just
didn't act like a lunatic and then when
he went to the graduation was all of a
sudden series he transitioned because he
was acting like wow lady at our
breakfast people spit in pancakes out
Diane laughing and then when you know
when everybody comes marching in the
students came in first and then the
people came in last
their fancy robes you know the [ __ ]
smart kids the mathletes and then the
guest speaker and he came walking in and
he had his hands on the shoulders of the
person in front of him and he was doing
this ridiculous walk and just came in
gone whoo ha and everybody died [ __ ]
laughing and but then and then he slowly
transitioned out and that made a few
jokes and he's up there and then he just
really started talking about light meat
guy eat old school entertainer they
don't make them like that anymore and I
can't say enough about that guy there's
another clip I would love to find a
Jerry Lewis
I cannot find it anywhere but I remember
I had just started my stand-up career
and I come home from some [ __ ]
godforsaken place in New England driving
my piece-of-shit car I get home and my
dad was still up and it was like I swear
to god I had to be like 1:30 in the
morning he's half asleep I'm burned out
from doing the show and driving and we
put on the TV and he's doing this whole
thing on Jerry Lewis and I make a long
story short here they they were talking
about you know how big you know Martin
and Lewis the comedy team Dean Martin
Jerry Lewis God and when they broke up
how everybody was blown away devastated
and they were wondering if they could
survive on their own so Jerry Lewis gets
his own show and it's the first episode
and they should basically this was the
bit they do like the old school thing
they got like a big band playing and
there's a shiny like shimmering [ __ ]
curtains and they go ladies and
gentlemen and the Jerry Lewis show and
rather than walking out like there was
this runway and he was standing at the
front of it and rather basically rather
than walking down to the end of the
runway he was standing at the front of
it and it was like motorized and it came
right out to the crowd so the shot is
you're looking at the curtains they're
playing the drum roll announcing him and
all you see is the back of their heads
and some people in the front row kind of
like sitting there like it's a nightclub
and they just go ladies and gentlemen
the Jerry Lewis show and he comes
through the curtains standing there in
this tuxedo not even look almost looking
like he's posing and he has the most
arrogant look on his face like he's the
and I'm sitting there watching it going
why is he acting so arrogant like he
should be humble right now like he
should make be making sure that his fans
are gonna follow him despite the fact
that they're probably pissed that he
left Dean Martin and he comes right up
to the front row and right when you
think the stage is gonna that's gonna
stop it plows into the front row when he
does this [ __ ] prat fall over the
table and steps on a chair and me and my
dad
you totally couldn't see it coming the
misdirection was he was standing there
so [ __ ] arrogant that he was so
focused on that you didn't see the
pratfall coming it's like 1:30 in the
morning
my dad's half asleep he [ __ ] falls
over the damn table and goes into the
chairs and crying laughing crying
laughing at 1:30 in the morning that's
how much of a beast Jerry Lewis is all
right there that's it all right ten
minute [ __ ] tribute on the podcast to
Jerry Lewis and once again youngsters I
did not come up with that lady thing
that's something I kind of started doing
with DeRosa and uninformed with just
big-time Jerry Lewis fans so so there
you go all right plowing ahead we got oh
let's do Laura why don't we do the rest
of the YouTube videos for this week we
got some great ones that will be at the
mmm podcast com
please remember to type in th e we'll
have all these YouTube videos right
there for you so you can just sit there
surfing the net alright this is a great
one Texas man gets a $330,000 home for
$16 this this is one of the greatest
stories I've ever seen this guy found a
loophole
basically the guy who owned the house
declared bankruptcy
he took off then the bank had it and I
can't remember I only watch the video
once there's something about there's
this loophole in Texas where if a house
is abandoned for a certain period of
time you can file this form it cost 16
bucks and you can claim the house and
this is what this guy did right it gets
better
everybody on the Block is pissed because
they paid like three hundred thirty
three hundred fifty thousand dollars for
their [ __ ] houses houses sorry and
this guy comes in he pays $16 for a
house so it brings the value of their
house down so they want him out of there
not only for that reason but I'm also
guessing cuz it's a black dude and
they're all white just I'm telling you
it's like when I watch this I'm like
this is the greatest beginning it's like
a pilot episode for the greatest [ __ ]
sitcom ever like the amount of
characters that you could have it's a
[ __ ] TV show so basically what this
guy has to do he has to stay there for
three years and and that the people on
the you gotta watch this video that his
neighbors they're trying to get him for
everything they're like but we just
think he should pay for his house like
everybody else
it's like you know what what sort of a
team player are you just because what
you signed yourself into indentured
servitude to these piece-of-shit bankers
one guy one guy gets out of it doesn't
have to become a [ __ ] slave to these
[ __ ] and you can't be happy for him
because he found a loophole because he
did his homework if you read about it
you could have owned two houses you
could have sold your house and then
moved into the other one for 16 bucks
quit hating on the guy I think it's the
greatest thing ever considering these
bankers took this bailout money they
don't eat they don't eat not only do
they not know where they don't know
where it is they can't say where it is
or who even got it
and they're breaking this guy's that was
like a billion trillion [ __ ] dollars
whatever this guy 330 grand you're mad
at that guy it's a [ __ ] genius you
know what I would do if I lived on that
block I would give that guy a [ __ ]
goddamn I don't know what I would make
him a bundt cake whatever the [ __ ] he's
supposed to do I'd welcome him to the
neighborhood I can I'd be like listen to
can you do me a favor can you read some
more documents and if you come up with
some other [ __ ] I would love if you
could find a loophole that somehow
affects my life like like this did
they're totally overlooking this guy's
talent you know you know it's funny
about that guy that blacked u2 moved
into
if he was actually on TV screaming about
how I bought a house for $16 half the
people on the [ __ ] Street would call
the 1-800 number in order his goddamn
book
you know and then if it turns out to be
a scam you'll never see the guy again
right the guy is on your block he's
right there go over and learn from him I
don't know I think it's I think it's
it's the greatest goddamn thing ever
considering recently I started looking
at homes out here because I've had
enough I've just had enough with living
over this guy I'm 43 with I'm still
living in one bedroom apartments and I
can't take it anymore I'm done I'm ready
to get back on the wheel
okay Illuminati you got me I'm gonna try
and find a place you know that I can try
and maybe pay off in 27 years you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys should be psyched
if I get a house cuz all that means is I
will be coming to a city near you
often because I'll have to pay for that
son of a [ __ ] over there unless they
find a loophole all right the next
YouTube video of this week is Buzz
Aldrin Buzz Aldrin an American Hero
all right fought World War two Air Force
pilot what else did he do he taught
other soldiers basically as far as I
know how to be that guy in the
Bombardier you know a little turret gun
you sitting there and basically an
aquarium bolted to the bottom of a
[ __ ] tank I mean an airplane the
balls that that took can you [ __ ]
believe that you know freaked out you
are you realize the balls it takes to go
to war the [ __ ] balls think about
that [ __ ] how scary is it to be flying
in an airplane you know you ever fly in
a commercial flight and you see another
commercial airline you start freaking
out like oh yeah again right and those
planes don't want to [ __ ] with each
other
got people air traffic controllers
making sure that they don't [ __ ] with
each other they got evens and odds evens
east to west
odds west to east I love the [ __ ] it
works out they make sure you don't run
into each other I just imagine if you're
on a in a [ __ ] plane there's people
on the ground trying to shoot it down
there's other smaller quicker more
nimble [ __ ] [ __ ] planes trying to
shoot your plane down and your job is
you got to climb down basically to where
the bag your [ __ ] check bags would be
and you climb into this little glass
bubble with a machine gun and you got to
sit there spinning around in the chair I
mean Jesus Christ how much screaming are
you doing down there I would just I
would be doing a three I'd probably
shoot my own [ __ ] plane I'd be so
scared and I guarantee you they probably
had some sort of safety device in there
so you wouldn't you know because if
you're following a plane like John Elway
trying to hit someone running a [ __ ]
post pattern yeah
and he starts from the left side of the
aircraft goes across the right you might
shoot the own [ __ ] tail off oh my god
what if somebody sort of breaks the
glass with whatever the [ __ ] they're
shooting and then you fall through it
well maybe you got a parachute on but
then where the hell are you landing in
enemy territory it's just unbelievable
the balls so Buzz Aldrin is part of this
fraternity of guys who yeah do you know
how he gets his flight suit on the size
of this guy's balls so anyways this this
[ __ ] YouTube video one of those moon
Conspirator people comes up to Buzz
Aldrin and starts calling him a coward
and a liar you're liar you're a coward
you never landed on the moon right and
first of all you know me I love a good
conspiracy but I don't get the whole we
didn't land on the moon conspiracy like
I'll go with it let's say we didn't who
does that hurt you know what did it hurt
didn't hurt anybody didn't send a bunch
of yeah we landed on it then everybody
jumped on a space shuttle and then they
just took him out the space and threw
him out the back door and they just came
back yeah they're on the move
and it was some [ __ ] conspiracy
theory to thin out the population out
here down here on earth they didn't do
any of that [ __ ] what were we trying to
do intimidate the Russians so they
didn't [ __ ] with us so we lied and said
that we couldn't the Russians be able to
figure that's what I love
the KGB couldn't figure out that we
didn't land on the moon but this tub is
[ __ ] who's yelling at this [ __ ] war
hero he somehow figured it out so
anyways he's following the guy around
and not to mention buzz at this point is
in his 80s okay so now you're yelling at
an old man all right a [ __ ] tough son
of a [ __ ] but an old negate there's a
certain level of respect the same reason
why I don't yell at that old [ __ ]
coop down below me I just don't yell at
the guy because he's an old DS an old
guy so this guy this [ __ ] tubby
goddamn [ __ ] just last guy picked in
gym class [ __ ] soft-serve ice cream
eating [ __ ] comes [ __ ] walking up to
the guy just sitting there going like
you're a liar you're a coward he said a
bunch of things to him he's fallen out
of the hotel into the street and there's
this woman and it wasn't the first time
he calls him a coward or something you
watch buzz turns around it reminded me
of like when I'm with my dog my pity
when like she starts fixating and I'm
watching the signs that okay she's going
into pitbull mode I got a I got a
snapper out of that it was the same
thing he started walking towards the
girl [ __ ] pulled him back no no no no
no and this guy wouldn't leave meloni
canned buzz keep saying leave me alone
leave me alone right and the guy keeps
getting his face and then the second
time he goes you're a liar you're a
coward and Buzz
[ __ ] right hook to this guy's fat
[ __ ] triple cheeseburger eatin face
he and this guy I swear to God was like
a foot taller than him and probably
outweighed him by a hundred fifty
[ __ ] pounds all quarter pounder with
cheese though right and he just drills
this guy in the face he backs him up
like three steps is an 81 year old man
and as much as I hate to admit it
that punch you you look at this punch I
would have fell down I'm not gonna lie
to you he would have hit me in my big
[ __ ] butcher block head and he would
have dropped me so props to Buzz Aldrin
but not only being a hero for punching a
fatty in the face you know what kills me
as buzz is not even that big a guy you
know and this dis really goes back to
this fascination that I have with that
generation of people you know the
Humphrey Bogart's the Lee Marvin's the
Charles Bronson's I know I've talked
about this before on my podcast where I
was just like why are those guys seemed
so much tougher than the movie stars of
today right look at Brad Pitt you like
at whatever that p90x lookin jackass
[ __ ] him right I don't give a f--- Matt
Damon a go [ __ ] yourself you don't give
a [ __ ] but you look at Lee Marvin you're
like doing I wouldn't [ __ ] with that guy
Telly Savalas I would not [ __ ] with him
either what is it that makes those guys
so tough is it cuz is it because the
stars today actually highlight their
hair you know what I realized it was I
looked up Lee Marvin somebody I watched
my entire life and knew so little about
Lee Marvin was one of the baddest dudes
ever the sound of his voice the way
carried himself he just like I wouldn't
fight the guy probably weighed like a
buck 40 buck forty five it's like I
would not [ __ ] with that guy ever I know
he could drink me under the table and
still kick the [ __ ] out of me I'm just I
would not [ __ ] with him ever so I
actually I went to his Wikipedia and I
looked up some [ __ ] this is why he was
so believable and all those tough-guy
roles this is why when he played a cop
and he was shooting a gun he looks so
believable and when he was in the big
red one and all those other movies he
was in he was so believable this is his
background Marvin left school to join
the United States Marine Corps serving
as a scout sniper in the 4th Marine
Division he was wounded in action during
the world war two battle of I'm gonna
butcher this Saipan site
say pan is an island off of the
Philippines and during this battle
during the battle which most of his
platoon were killed
Marvin's wound in the buttocks from a
machine-gun fire which severed his
sciatic nerve he was awarded the Purple
Heart and was given a medical discharge
with the rank of private first class
okay do you understand the difference
between a guy like that pretending to be
in war when he's actually been in it as
opposed to some [ __ ] douche like me
if I ever booked a war movie and I'm
trying to grow some scruff and have a
cigarette dangling from my lip huh is
this what a [ __ ] war hero looks like
that's why that's why that's why buzz at
81 years old [ __ ] with one right hook
81 year old man backed up that fat
Michael Moore looking jackass that's why
they've been through it so this is what
this is what I love about this [ __ ] so a
positive of us over the last 10 years
being having two wars at the same time
I'm telling you we got some we got some
badass movie stars coming our way in the
next 10 years we get out of these wars
I'm telling you these kids are coming
back and they're gonna redo the
Magnificent Seven and I'm gonna tell you
they're gonna have that vibe again that
I wouldn't [ __ ] with that dude and I
guarantee you they're not highlighting
their hair all right so there you go
please check out Lee Marvin I'm telling
you if you feel like a [ __ ] just
imitate half the [ __ ] he does I'm
telling you probably get 40% more [ __ ]
in the first week I guarantee it am i
selling that guy who bought a house for
16 bucks
next next YouTube video we got is uh
Pizza Hut in India I don't know what's
going on here but it's a Pizza Hut and
all of a sudden it's sort of hammer time
and they start doing this synchronized
dance what I really think it is is this
it's so overpopulated in
in India that it in order to even
maintain a job at Pizza Hut you know you
know you always have that I'm
tap-dancing for the man in India you
literally have to do it I think they
have a dance contest at the end of every
shift and whoever does the worst loses
their job and then they bring in a new
employee for even less money and then
they have a dance-off at the end of
every one of them I don't know probably
a documentary at some point and I
believe that is that it is that it for
the [ __ ] yeah alright we're bringing
another topic back here everybody
well let me height mice my [ __ ] here for
this week how about that I'm gonna be at
the Montreal Comedy Festival everybody
as you're listening to this on Monday I
am probably already there I've flown
across this country for the nine
millionth time in my life and I am gonna
be at the Montreal Comedy Festival with
Robert Kelly and Joe DeRosa the young
teen idol sensation from the Opie and
Anthony program we're gonna be doing a
show called cheat life which is based on
it off of our short film that you can
actually see Saturday night at the
Montreal Comedy Festival it will be
airing up there and what else I don't
know if I mentioned this we're also
writing a book based off of it when the
book comes out the hard copy of the
movie will be available until then
you'll only be able to see the movie in
short film festivals which they have at
the Montreal Comedy Festival so please
if you're in the area come on out check
us out if if you're in the States you're
anywhere near nearby I suggest you fly
up you watch some great comedy and
Montreal some of the most beautiful
women I've ever seen in my life some of
the most beautiful ladies you're ever
gonna see in your life
beautiful architecture it's not hockey
season so you don't have to worry about
anybody rioting although it probably
will be ungodly hot which means all
those beautiful girls will be in summer
dresses so why don't you stand there in
a raincoat like me with your hands in
your pockets and have a good goddamn
time
all right we're bringing back an old
topic here one that I actually said I'd
stop doing because I heard tosh point-o
does some
like this but people keep asking me
questions this is another installment of
the once canceled but now returned is it
races braces alright bill I had a recent
episode that didn't really turn out that
bad but I felt really bad about it I'm
in the medical field and one day someone
I work with was going down to the
cappuccino cart to get some Java Jesus
Christ dude what [ __ ] stratosphere are
you living in you're a doctor you get
cappuccino carts and the Java that just
sounds you sound like you're in Paris
that's how that sounds in my world I
remember I had a real job I unload
trucks I went over to [ __ ] D'Angelo's
I got a steak and cheese anyways they
asked me if I would like anything and I
told him what this is let me get back to
this at the cappuccino cart they asked
me if I would like anything I told him I
wanted a large coffee they asked me what
would I like in it and I said the old
line I like my coffee hot sweet and
black like my women as soon as that came
out of my mouth I look behind me to see
a female african-american medical
student I was pretty sure she heard me
and my gut fell into my pelvis was shame
since I was in a position of authority
over her I felt particularly embarrassed
she never indicated that she had heard
anything but since I have a loud mouth
I'm absolutely certain she did well
staring at while staring at her I didn't
know what to say so I backpedaled by
saying haven't you seen that movie
airplane that's a line from the movie
she said no but still never indicated
she had heard my comment so I just said
oh I was just saying a line from a movie
anyhow nothing ever developed of it but
I felt that if I apologized it might
have embarrassed her and there was the
remote possibility that she hadn't heard
me to anyway anyhow I felt bad about it
and guilty so bill is it racist no no
you're you're just you were unlucky
because the second you said how do you
like your coffee
I don't remember hot and sweet I just
remember how do you like your coffee and
that little white girl they're like two
eight-year-old kids talking how do you
like your coffee it was already funny
that she was ordering coffee and I
remember that the line I take it black
like my men that's that's not that was
actually the actual line so this even
though you switched it up that's
immediately what I thought I was like oh
that's the line from airplane so you
hope you're quoting a movie you just
yeah and the fact that you actually are
self-aware enough that it made it even
worse that you were in a position of
power over her that tells me that you're
a good dude that just was a very awkward
moment and hats off to her if she
actually heard you because she really
could have turned that into this giant
[ __ ] thing over nothing I quoted a
movie you know I quoted a [ __ ] movie
and then it would have just been like
why didn't you quote another movie why
didn't you say I liked it I liked it
creamy like the band you know and then
that would be some horrific [ __ ] for
people to yell about on the view why do
I always pick on that show I never watch
it alright overrated underrated for the
week
underrated Nia's contributions to the
Monday morning podcast I got to read
that one to her her egos gonna go
through the roof overrated I actually
agree with you overrated putting NSFW
not not not safe for work I guess is
what that stands for putting NSFW not
safe for work on racy email for words if
you're screwing over your employer by
cruising Facebook or the internet on the
clock you're already doing something
wrong you should either be cut and learn
a thing or two or already know how not
to get caught in either scenario it's
not my responsibility to help you cheat
your timecard if by chance you happen to
have the awesome job of having to watch
YouTube at work the whole safe thing
shouldn't be an issue anyways should be
an issue anyways I don't know I don't
know anything about that
is that what you guys do at work instead
of working why you [ __ ] listen to
this right now aren't you
so anyways this is the end of the
podcast here I usually I don't know how
to bring this type of stuff up other
than just to bring it up obviously
condolences go out to all the victims
and everybody in in Norway just
unbelievably devastating to hear that
news I'm gonna be there in October so I
don't know hopefully that's one of those
things you know something like that
happens that bad and you're like oh my
god I'm gonna stand on stage and act
silly you know I just realized and I
just sent a roundabout way take tragedy
and use it as a way to hype my [ __ ]
mic my shows that's a terrible tragedy
over there no heed Norway and
incidentally I'll be over there on the
19th of October I knew I shouldn't have
brought it up I don't know I don't know
how to how to gracefully handle those
things that's [ __ ] horrific and
something like that has obviously
happened way too many times here in this
country so I hope that's the last time I
hope you got the guy who did it and I
don't know I don't know what else to say
I guess there is nothing to say well
Jesus Christ bill what a great [ __ ]
way to end the podcast now what do I do
how about I read something about CBS I
figured I had to say something right
show that you gave a [ __ ] my heart was
in the right place people of Norway all
right here we go CBS backs off from a
more customer-friendly rewards practice
contrary to what the drugstore chains
marketing chief said last year the firm
isn't working to add extra bucks to
consumers extra you know wait let's go
back to Norway for half a second you
know what's gonna be [ __ ] up about
this is how the NRA is gonna use this as
an opportunity to start going like well
if everybody had guns they could have
[ __ ] shot at him you know and I'm
actually Pro I believe that people
should be able to arm themselves you
know I actually believe that [ __ ] but I
always it's [ __ ] up that the NRA
always does that sure they don't even
wait they don't wait like half a [ __ ]
second
when something horrific like that
happens and they gotta come in you know
a Charlton Heston would come in with his
musket and hold it over his [ __ ] head
you know like you just want to met a
medal in [ __ ] Mexico City
you remember that it'd be nice if they
if they had like a five-day wait period
before they were just like and this is
why I machine guns should they label um
contrary to what the dry write CBS back
to CBS here do I really want to read all
of this I don't think I want to read
this do I
oh by the way somebody sent me something
some homeless guy in Texas went in and
robbed a bank he said I have a gun so
they bring over our stack of cash he
takes a hundred-dollar bill out of the
stack of cash he gives the rest of it
back he goes he pays for his room and
gets himself some to eat the next day he
turns himself in says I wasn't raised to
do something like that all right
he goes to trial they give him 15
[ __ ] years all right now the guy did
rob a bank
bank the guy did rob a bank so I get it
you're like all right well this guy is a
[ __ ] loose cannon
all right so all right he gets 15 years
the person sends me this link I'm
reading this other story one of these
piece of [ __ ] bankers who was involved
in a three-book billion-dollar fraud
scheme you know what he got he got three
years so there's the lesson people if
you're gonna rob a bank take all the
money so you can hire a lawyer they can
get you out of the [ __ ] or at least dude
three billion dollar fraud you you ought
to be in jail for the rest of your life
that's what I would love to see with all
these piece of [ __ ] bankers I would just
love to see them locked up for life you
know no more loafers
no more cufflinks no more yachts you
know no more hiring the [ __ ] Rolling
Stones to play your private party that
was paid for by old people's [ __ ]
pensions and they're out there eating
Alpo and you're over there getting Ron
Wood to show you how to do a G chord
really you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I swear to God I think they should all
have to dress like bankers I think that
she should wear a little top hat dressed
like the penguin and Batman and I should
walk around like that and then we should
all get BB guns and just shoot him in
the [ __ ] ass every time you walk in
there I wonder what's wrong my money and
when he bends over in the safe he just
shoot him right in the butt cheek would
that be nice just something some sort of
punishment to taking all that [ __ ]
money what else do I have anything else
um oh I know I have I actually watched
the Chicago Fire vers Man United game
you know cuz I watched the lay soccer
game last week and I get into it and it
was a typical thing when American team
plays a team from another country we
always play the first half we're doing
great and like holy [ __ ] we're gonna be
we're gonna beat Man Man United with
that [ __ ] dude Kelly even I know his
goddamn name guys a beast
what happens they score [ __ ] three
goals in like five minutes which I can't
even explain to Americans what would how
difficult that is to do in soccer you
know you know it's [ __ ] weird about
the Chicago Fire is that's a tragedy
where a bunch of people died and then
years later you just you know it's like
I have in the Honolulu Pearl Harbor
attack right now Jesus bill really are
we going to you did you that far out of
[ __ ] jokes all right I'm you know
what I know when to tap out that's it
I'm out of comedy go [ __ ] yourselves
Allah I'm gonna bring this [ __ ] up to uh
up to Montreal I'm gonna try to do a
podcast with Bobby Kelly and uh Joe
Young Joe DeRosa young Joe DeRosa by the
way everybody Joe DeRosa has joined a
gym so uh next time you see him at a
show do me a favor just be like Joe
you're looking good idea you going to
the gym or something and when he goes
yeah I am and just be like I'm just
[ __ ] with you bill told me that
you're going to a gym you look just as
[ __ ] mushy as he ever did laugh in
his face and walk away could you do that
for me if you can't do that go to the go
to the mmm podcast.com and if you'd like
to make a donation
this free [ __ ] podcast that I do out
of the goodness of my heart it's not to
stroke my own ego it's not to sell
tickets it's to uh to give you guys free
entertainment I am a martyr there's a
donation button there I appreciate
everybody who's made all the donations
you have any little bit that you send in
always helps always helps that is it the
mmm podcast com is the official pant
fanpage that's it that's the podcast for
this week I hope you guys have a great
week
and once again Montreal Comedy Festival
this week later on next month August I
will be in Reno
August 6th at the Golden Nugget Casino
or some [ __ ] like that I don't have it
in front of me and I'm gonna be at
Zanies in Nashville towards the end of
the month and the stress Factory in New
Jersey so you guys come on down come on
out to a show yell out cube steak I'll
tell you the rest of that [ __ ] story
all right
that's it see you
[Music]